Good morning. We're reconvening for the January 13th, 14th, 2021 state board meeting. First
announcement for public input. Members of the public wishing to dial in for public comments
should view the live stream of the meeting to know at what time we will ask for public
comment for each item on the agenda. Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone
number and participant access code, then following each of the operator's prompts. Upon dialing in,
callers will be added to a caller queue. The operator will notify callers when it is their
turn to provide public comment. We will also ask the public calling in for public comment to please
turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they are following the live feed to avoid an
echoing effect. Public comment will be limited to one minute for each speaker, and board members
please mute your microphones when not speaking and keep your cameras on at all times except during
the scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout today's virtual meeting. For
each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for you board members to raise your hand using the
zoom participant window if you would like to ask a question or make a comment. And we're going to
go to item 16, which is the state annual performance report for part B of the individuals with
disabilities education act of 2004 covering program year 2019 to 2020. I just need to take
role to establish a quorum. Okay, thank you. So we're going to change it up. We'll go reverse
order from yesterday just to keep things lively. So member Burr. He's here. I usually see member
Burr representatives here and we will work on the mute function. Now they got me unmuted. I am here.
All right, excellent. President Darling-Hammond. Here. Member Fatah.
Here. Member Glover-Woods. Here. Member McQuillan. Here. Member Navo. Here. Member Patil-Brownson.
Here. Good morning. Morning. Member Rodriguez. Here. Member Rucker. I am here. Vice President
Strauss. Here. Member Son. Here. Everyone's present. Quorum's established. All right.
We will now move on with agenda item 16, which is the state annual performance report for part
B of the Individuals with Disabilities Education Act of 2004 covering the program year 2019-20.
The CDE recommends the state board review and approve the executive summary of the
fiscal year 2019 annual performance report for part B of IDEA as prepared by the special education
division and the item will be presented by Heather Kalamis of the CDE. Heather recently
joined the department in August 2020 taking on the role of special education director.
This is her first meeting presenting before the board, so I'd like to welcome Heather.
Great. Thank you so much, Linda Darling-Hammond, and good morning, SBE board members. It's an honor
and a pleasure to be with you here today to discuss the annual performance report. I myself,
along with Shiloh Duncan-Bessarreal, will be co-presenting and presenting the annual
performance report to you here this morning and looking forward to the conversation.
As board member Darling-Hammond stated previously, I most previously come from
the Illinois State Board of Education as the former state director of special education
and also the executive director of programs which oversaw the special education
multilingual and early childhood departments. Prior to that, I'm a lifelong special educator.
I've been a paraprofessional, a teacher, a special education administrator, and it's been such a joy
and such an honor to join an amazing team here at the California Department of Education, so
thank you all. Next slide. And in terms of my philosophy and approach to special education,
I believe that we must ensure that our systems and structures are aligned to values and beliefs
that support and elevate the student experience, which is also a human experience, and that special
education provides opportunities. And really, to steal from Tom Hare, who I'm a big fan of,
is to minimize the impact of the disability and maximize outcomes for students. And all along the
way, it's a goal and an approach to build upon the brilliance that lies within each of our students
as well. And so I think the role of the special education within the California Department of
Education is to obviously fulfill our various federal and state requirements in terms of
general supervision, but also I'm looking for our division to support, empower, and embolden our
LEAs to relentlessly and collaboratively seek solutions that positively impact students, families,
and communities. And there's a slide a little bit later that digs a little bit deeper into the APR,
but just a brief overview here is that the Individuals with Disabilities Education Act,
or IDEA, requires each state to develop a state performance plan every six years and then
subsequently provide an annual performance report on targets that evaluate the state's efforts to
implement the requirements of IDEA across the state. And so obviously, this is our annual update
that will be submitted to OSEP upon approval. OSEP determines and uses data within the APR
to make annual determinations for each state, typically around June or July. And those sort
of categories that states are designated as meeting requirements, needing assistance,
needing intervention, or needing substantial intervention. And so just a historical note
is that the state of California has been in the needs assistance category since 2015. So
2015 to 2020, California has been designated as a needs assistance state, which just means that
the Office of Special Education Programs and the U.S. Department of Education do provide
technical assistance and opportunities for enhanced support to improve special education
programming. So to provide you a brief overview of the landscape of students with disabilities in
California, during the 2019 and 2020 school year, there were just north of 804,000 students with
disabilities ages 0 to 22 that were served in the California public school system.
Of that, there were just north of 752,000 that are K-12 students with disabilities,
which represent just a little over 12% of the total percent of California student population,
which is just over six million. And to put that in perspective, in that same,
in that actually the 2018-2019 school year on a national landscape, the national average is
roughly around 14%. So California is in that ballpark range of averages in terms of supporting
students with disabilities. Next slide. In terms of enrollment over time, really within the past
decade, as you can see here, well the font may be a little bit small, the population of students
with disabilities across the state of California has risen in 2009 at around 10%. And then in the
2019-2020 school year, again, looking at 12% over time. So it paints a pretty interesting picture
of the trajectory and the growth of students with disabilities in the state of California. Next slide.
In terms of students with disabilities listed by categorical designation in 2019 and 2020,
here we see a spread that's typical of many states and reflects sort of a national
sort of a percentage of data, or I'm sorry, categorical designations of students with
disabilities in specific designations or categories. And so SLD, or specific
learning disabilities, are a category that has the most amount of students identified,
at roughly 37%, followed by speech-language impairment, autism, other health impairment,
or known as OHI, and then intellectual disability. And again, this is typical in terms of a
distribution at the national landscape as well. In terms of students that are socially
economically disadvantaged, that also have an IEP in 2019-2020, here we see that 13%
of students that also carry that designation also have an IEP as well.
In terms of foster youth with IEPs in that same year, here we see a little bit bigger number of
27% of students that are designated as foster youth also have an IEP as well.
And in terms of English learners that have IEPs within the 2019-2020 school year, again,
we are sitting right at 17%. And then percent of students with IEPs in one or more of the LCFF
student groups, here we see that roughly 70% of our students with IEPs are in one or more
roughly 70% of our students with IEPs are in one or more of the LCFF student groups as well.
And so again, just as a piggyback off of what I discussed a little bit earlier,
again, the APR has very specific instructions in terms of how it's prepared in terms of
information that is required to be submitted to the ED. Again, the state board must approve.
There are 17 indicators located in the annual performance report. And those are either
categorized as compliance and performance. And then there's one that is both considered
compliance and performance. And so the targets for the compliance indicators are set by OSEP at either
zero or 100. And then the targets for the performance indicators are set in collaboration
with various groups here in terms of setting those targets, collaborating collectively across
the state. And so such as those targets will be submitted to the state board of education later
this year for discussion and approval as well. And it's important to note that our state
performance plan and those targets will run through 2019-2020. And so we'll be developing
an additional round of targets again with stakeholder collaboration.
And then in terms of just data years, I think it's important to know, and I know Shiloh will also
echo this as well, is that this current APR that you're seeing today reflects data that
was collected during federal fiscal year 2019. And so this is actually equivalent to California
school year 2019-2020. It is important to note that certain indicators like graduation dropout,
suspension, and expulsion are indicators that are reported in lag years. So again,
the data that you're seeing is from school year 2018 and 2019. Next slide. And in terms of where
did this data come from? Well, the data that is collected from a variety of sources, CALPADS being
one, the Office of Administrative Hearings second, and then the California Assessment of Student
Performance in Progress or CASP. And in this point, just because the CASP is not actually
applicable in this submission because of the federal requirements for testing were waived
at this point in time. So I will now pass it over to my colleague, Shiloh Duncan-Vessarille,
who will take us through an overview of the compliance indicators and then an overview of
the performance indicators. Good morning, board members. It's so lovely to see you virtually,
although I'm seeing some familiar faces and some new faces. So for those of you who do not know me,
my name is Shiloh Duncan-Vessarille. I'm the data administrator for special education.
So my primary goal is to collect and report on all students with disabilities in California.
I've been here before talking about our annual performance report. And so I wanted to walk you
through the report. If you've gotten a chance to look at the actual item itself, you'll notice
there are 17 indicators. I will not be going through each indicator today. Thankfully,
I know it's quite early for that kind of data dive. We're going to be selecting some of the
indicators, but I'm happy to answer questions on any indicators that are in the item.
As Heather spoke to, we do have data that's coming from 2019 and 2019-20 and 2018-19.
It's important to note, though, that this data doesn't always reflect the full year of 2019-20.
We do know that COVID school site closures were impacting the data. And so the data you are
going to see, most of it is actually going to come from the fall of 2019. And so that's prior
to COVID school site closures. Something to note for future years is that we do believe that
the impact of both COVID school site closures and also learning loss will be impacted on the
annual performance report for multiple years to come, at least two or three years.
So something to keep in mind, because we have laggier data.
So I'm going to start with the compliance indicators. It's important to note that
compliance indicators have a target of either 0% or 100%. We don't set these targets as a state.
They are given to us by the Office of Special Education Programs at the U.S. Department of
Education, and we cannot change them. And they're very difficult to meet. You'll notice we get close
on a few indicators, but we never meet the actual target itself. But there I think are some positive
things that we're going to be pointing out in these sets of indicators. So I'd like to start
with indicator 4B, suspension expulsion rate by race and ethnicity. I always like to start with
this indicator in part because it is an indicator that sounds like other types of indicators,
but is actually very different. So indicator 4B is actually a disproportionality indicator, meaning
we're looking at suspension and expulsion rate by race and ethnicity. And while we are looking at
suspension expulsion, we are looking at the cumulative number of days that a student is
suspended or expelled greater than 10 days. So if a student is expelled greater than 10 days
cumulatively through the year, they are counted as part of this calculation. And the LEA, we count
the total number of those instances by the LEA and compare it by the composition of race and ethnicity.
So it's also important to note the reason that this is a compliance indicator is that calculation
is just the first step. What we do then is we identify districts that do have some significant
discrepancy in race and ethnicity for suspension and expulsion, and then we dig deeper inside of
their policies, practices, and procedures. And if we find instances of non-compliance, those are the
representation that you see in the percentage here. So around 4% of LEAs that we identified that
had significant discrepancy also had non-compliance that we follow up with to ensure that there isn't
non-compliant policies and procedures. Of course, we did not meet the 0% requirement in this indicator.
We were pretty close at 0.79%. Indicator 9 is another disproportionate representation indicator.
We look at disproportionate representation overall in this indicator. So does the
identification of all students with disabilities differ in composition of race and ethnicity
compared to the composition of race and ethnicity for the entire district? As you can see here,
this is very similar to the indicator 4B, where we are again identifying a district that has
disproportionate representation, and then we're digging deeper into their policies, practices,
and procedures to determine if there are non-compliances. And in this case, we found
about 2% of districts had disproportionate representation. Again, we did not meet the
target at about 2%. It's also important to note that we did increase the number of districts by
0.45% compared to the previous year who had non-compliance policies, practices, and procedures.
Finally, disproportionate representation by disability, that's again looking at the number
of students who are identified for special education by the disability type and comparing
the composition of race and ethnicity to what we expect in the composition of race and ethnicity
in the entire district. We found about 14% of those districts we flagged as having disproportionate
representation by disability as having non-compliant policies, practices, and procedures,
and that's an increase of about 4.2% from the previous year. We are again always refining the
number of items that we identify and we look at when we dig deeper into a district, and we did
increase the number of items that we looked at this year, so that could potentially account for
the increase of 4.2%. I do also like to take a moment here to talk about disproportionality and
also significant disproportionality, and for those of you who've been with us for a little
while, you'll remember our many conversations about this, but for those of you that are new,
I'd like to walk you through how we sort of got here in terms of disproportionality and
significant disproportionality. Both of these elements are required elements within IDA for
us to ensure that there isn't disproportionate identification of students for race ethnicity,
by race ethnicity, for identification, for suspension, expulsion, and also for
placement. Prior to 2016, states could use any kind of calculation they wanted,
and we used a sort of a mix of two calculations. In 2016, the U.S. certification changed the
regulation and required the use of a single calculation called the risk ratio to make these
determinations. It also required the state to set a minimum end size, a minimum cell size,
and to define recent progress. We applied the new methodology to disproportionality
starting in 2016-17, and the reason I bring this up is because disproportionality that you see here
in the annual performance report today is just a one-year calculation. The significant
disproportionality looks at multiple years. One of the things that we did in California, though,
was we applied the same methodology to both the one-year disproportionate calculation that we do
within the annual performance report and inside of the three-year calculation for significant
disproportionality because we wanted districts to use the time between year one and year three
to really look at their practices, their policies, any sort of trainings, any sort of work that they
wanted to to reduce the impact of disproportionality and to reduce the possibility that would become
significantly disproportionate because there is an additional level of enforcement that occurs when
a district becomes significantly disproportionate. For this school year, so FFY 2019, we identified
332 LEAs who were found to be disproportionate in that one-year calculation and 111 LEAs who
were significantly disproportionate, and it should be noted that is an increase in the number of
districts that we identified in previous calculations prior to 2016-17. The reason for
that is because I should note that the risk ratio is a single calculation that is also very
sensitive to size, and so we've worked with US Smart Education to sort of minimize that impact,
but we are identifying more districts as being both disproportionate and significantly disproportionate.
So when we talk about disproportionality and significant disproportionality, it's important
to understand that what you see in the annual performance report today is the disproportionality
one-year calculation. Again, we flag districts and we do a compliance review to dig a little bit
deeper into their policies, practices, and procedures. After three years of the district
disproportionate in the same indicator, then there's fiscal implications. So what we do is
we set aside 15 percent of their federal funds for IDEA and they're required to develop an
improvement plan. And so why it was really important for us to ensure that we had a step
process for districts and disproportionality and to adopt the same calculation for both
disproportionality and significant disproportionality is because we wanted disproportionality, the
one-year calculation, to act as an early warning system for significant disproportionality for
LEAs. As such, the first two years, the districts would potentially identify root cause and change
their practices, but if they did not change their practices, then they would have that impact of
fiscal consequence. And that's that 111 districts that are in significant disproportionality this
year. I'm also going to overview the performance indicators. Again, there's a number of performance
indicators. I will not be overviewing every single one of them. We're just going to select
some of them to go through, but I'm happy to answer any questions about the individual
indicators in the item. So I do have this information here in both the item and here,
and it's important to note the things that we identified in this item is we identified the
target, the result, whether or not we met the target, and the change. And the reason I wanted
to show you all this and talk a little bit about it is because, as Heather spoke about earlier,
we will be coming back to you sometime later this year, in the fall likely, to walk through
our targets that we've worked with our stakeholder group on and sort of walk through each individual
performance indicator, look at the target that the stakeholders have
recommended, and then move forward with your recommendations so that we can submit it to the
U.S. Department of Education in February of 2022. So I would normally bring our assessment indicator,
which is indicator three to you all, but as you know, due to COVID-19 and school site closures
around the state of California, the city suspended statewide testing. There is no assessment data
for 2019-20, and we will not be submitting data for this indicator. We also received a waiver from
the U.S. Department of Education that did not require us to submit the data for this indicator.
All states receive this waiver, so there will be no statewide data for any state
submitted in their annual performance report. So again, talking about suspension expulsion,
when Heather talked about there's one indicator that is both compliance and performance,
it's suspension and expulsion, and so this one looks at how many students are being
suspended or expelled greater than 10 days cumulative in a school year. This is a lag
indicator, so that's important to note, meaning we're only looking at 2018-19 data in this indicator.
The reason I bring this up is because the impact of school site closures and the impact on suspension
expulsion data that we will see next year, and we will also likely see the impact of distance learning
on this indicator as well. There's obviously just not going to be as much suspension expulsion that
we would see in a normal school year, so we will see an impact on this indicator next year, and
we'll probably see an impact in the following year as well. For 2018-19, we did identify an
increase of 1.1% to a total of 2.51% of students with disabilities who are suspended or expelled
greater than 10 days. I also wanted to bring least restrictive environment to you all. This
is placement. This is a very, very important indicator for us because we believe that students
are placed in the right environment. They have a reduction in behavior concerns and also an
increase in access to the general education curriculum. It's a multi-level indicator,
meaning we're looking at a couple of three different areas. We're looking at the number
of students who are in regular class greater than 80% of the day. That's 5A. You're looking at
students who are inside the regular class less than 40% of the day. That would be 5B,
and students who have served in public or private separate schools, residential facilities,
or homebound placement, that is indicator 5C. We did meet the target for each one of these indicators,
and we did go in the right direction. But as you know, and I've talked about this indicator in
previous years for those of you who have heard me talk about this multiple times, we are making
progress in this indicator. We're just not making a lot of progress in this indicator. We would want
to see a greater number. So right now, we're sitting at around 58% of students with disabilities
in California who are inside the regular class greater than 80% of the day. We would want to
see a larger number than that. These are children who would have full inclusion and access to the
general education curriculum, and we would want to see more of that because we believe that translates
into better outcomes for students with disabilities. It should be noted, though,
that California is very large, and so what does that mean? So every percentage that you see here
equates to 7,000 more students having access to the general education curriculum
more than 80% of the day, and so I think we want to sort of work with our partners in LEAs and with
CELPAs to help move this number a little bit further, but it is good news that we have around
10,000 more students who have access in 2019-20 to a general education curriculum in a Least
Restricted Environment. I also want to talk about our preschool Least Restricted Environment. I
don't have as much good news on this one as I do on our other one. So this is again a multi-level
indicator. 6A looks at the percent of students receiving a regular early childhood program,
receiving their services in the regular early childhood program, and 6B is the percent of
students in a separate education, class, school, or facility. What we're seeing this year in 2019,
we are seeing that fewer students have access to their services in a regular early childhood
program than they did in the previous year, a decrease of about 2% and more students were
in separate special education classes, schools, or facilities, and these are again children who
are ages three to five. So we are definitely seeing a trend in the long direction. We would
want to see more students having their services in a regular early childhood program.
And then finally, we're going to talk a little bit about indicator 14, another multi-level
indicator. It looks at 14A is the number of students who are no longer in secondary school,
so they left school the previous year, and they're enrolled in some type of post-secondary
school within one year of leaving high school. 14B looks at students who are competitively employed
and who are in some type of post-secondary school within one year of leaving high school,
and then 14C are students who have IPs who left school the previous year, and they're
enrolled in some kind of higher education, some type of post-secondary school, or a training
program, or their competitively employment, and some other employment. So it's sort of a rolling
indicator looking at those three different things. We are seeing a trend in the long
looking at those three different things. We are happy that we met this indicator, and last year
we came to you all. You will see that we did not meet the indicator for 14B, which is competitive
employment, but we are encouraged the fact that we are now much closer to meeting the target,
or we are meeting the target, and we have increased by about 5% over the previous year for
students who are competitively employed. So we want our meeting indicator for each one of these
sub-indicators. So I want to turn it back over to Heather to sort of talk about the next steps for
this APR and about some of the priority areas, and also take questions from the board members as well.
Great, thank you so much, Shiloh. Obviously in terms of next steps, as stated earlier,
this would go back before the state board for approval and then a submission to OSEP
in early February. In terms of priority areas within the special education division, there's
several, there's many, and so don't want to give you the laundry list today, and we have time to
sort of really discuss priority areas over time, but there are really some priority areas that I
think are worth noting for us here today, and one of those is really ensuring that our components
of what we call the general supervision are fully functioning, healthy, and sort of talking to one
another, and what I mean by that is that the components of general supervision, as really
described by the Office of Special Education Programs, or OSEP, are comprised of the state
performance plan, which includes obviously the annual performance report, policies, procedures,
effective implementation, integrated monitoring, fiscal management, data, improvement on correction
activities and incentives, effective dispute resolution, and targeted TA and professional
development to the field, and so these are things that our division within CDE covers, and so
it's important for us to really focus on ensuring that those components are functioning and
healthy to really support improved progress over time as well, so looking forward to digging into
those specific areas so that we can continue to move the needle forward for students with disabilities.
In terms of another just priority area, obviously, is that the need for continued discussion and
innovation around, you know, whether it's distance or hybrid or even small group learning
during the pandemic continues to remain a focus for us here at CDE to support and assist
our partners in the field to continue to provide the needed and necessary supports and services
for our students so that they continue to thrive during this time. Another focus of our division,
which is really exciting, is really stepping into the early intervention and early childhood
space and really looking at that intersection of our part C to B services so that we do end up
with more students than not ending up in inclusive pre-K and Kinder programs as well.
As you saw on the slide earlier, English learners with disabilities comprise roughly 17%
of our students with disabilities, and for me, that is a huge focus area and an area of opportunity
for, I think, some really innovative work in terms of how we address the unique needs of students
who are also English learners across the state. Teacher recruitment and retention of a truly
diverse workforce is also key and critical to ensure that our students have high quality
teachers and support staffs in front of them each and every day. And as Shiloh noted before, in terms
of just post-secondary transitions, and it's great that we're doing better in that area,
and that really the focus is to ensure that our students, upon leaving our K-12 system,
have multiple pathways for students to realize and maximize their independence and dispel
those limiting beliefs on what can and cannot be done for them as well. Like I said before,
there are honestly many more priorities, but we appreciate the time here for you to discuss today
and just know that the investment and excitement around special education in California is quite
frankly astonishing, and I'm excited that we have positioned ourselves to do groundbreaking
work on our journey ahead. So thank you, and I look forward to the next time that we meet,
and happy to answer any questions for you at this time.
Thank you for that thorough presentation. At this point, we're going to open the phone line
for the public comment queue, and if you could put the public comment slide up, that would be
terrific. Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item can do so by calling the
number that will soon be on the slide. Who has that slide? Yes, I'll put it up real quick. Great,
thank you. Members of the public wishing to provide comment can do so by calling the number
that will soon appear on this slide and entering the access code. While we're waiting for members
of the public to call in, I want to ask Vice President Strauss if she has any initial comments
as liaison. Then I'll ask board members if they want to ask one clarifying question or make a
comment before we go to public comment, which will be followed by board discussion. Board members,
can you please raise your hand in the participant panel of the Zoom at this time if you have a
clarifying question? First of all, Heather, welcome to the state board. Again, I echo
President Darling-Hammond's welcome to California. We're delighted that you've
joined our Department of Education, and we look forward to continuing to work with you and benefit
from your strong experience and leadership in Illinois before you came here. Thank you so much.
Shiloh, thank you for all the work on the data. As a liaison to the Advisory Commission on Special
Ed, I see Shiloh's work consistently, and I just have to say we are so fortunate that you all are
supporting our students of special needs in California. This is an annual temperature check
for us on where we are in California, and I just appreciate the data that show us really the big
picture in California. I appreciate that we're making progress, although slow, and we recognize
that this is lag data, and it doesn't really give us really data on how we're doing during COVID. We
know local districts have their own data and how they're monitoring their students with special
needs, but I do think it really highlights for us some priority areas, which Heather talked about,
and one that I really appreciate is the conversation about disproportionality, because
I think that's actually helped districts who hadn't maybe paid attention to that because
their overall data show different information, and I think this kind of helps kind of push the
conversation about least restrictive environment, looking for first best instruction and tier one
instruction before students are identified for special needs services, and so I think this report
and this process, while data heavy, is actually a good tool for us to guide districts. So just so
in March we're going to be talking about this again, and in March we're going to hear about
technical assistance and what the CDE is doing to help with this data supporting local education
agencies looking at the discrepancies and the areas of need, and so I think it's an area that
we will continue to talk about, and I appreciate again so much the leadership, the voices on the
advisory commission on special ed, and the work that everybody's doing in this really challenging
time to make sure they reach our students with special needs. We know they're having a really
hard time, some of the most challenging in the COVID hybrid learnings and remote learning. So
with that I'll turn it over back to President Darlingham and any board members that have any
comments. Thank you. Well I want to get to the public comment before we get into discussion,
but if there are any clarifying questions we can take those. I'm not seeing any at the moment.
So we will go ahead with public comment and then we'll come back for our board discussion.
We have one caller in the queue for item number 16. Caller,
please state your name and affiliation for your record. Your time starts now.
Caller, are you available?
Okay, they may have called in for the wrong item. Thank you and there are no more callers in the
queue. Thank you. All right, so we'll go ahead if there's any board discussion before we take a
motion on approving this performance report. Is there any further? I see a hand. Member Navo.
Thank you and good morning everyone and Heather welcome and it's great to have you and Shiloh
as well always appreciate the deep dive into the data and I really just want to offer just a
kudos and maybe some food for thought. Really want to thank you for highlighting Shiloh again
the indicator five and although we're meeting the as you noted meeting the indicator requirements
when you look at that on page 19 and you you look at the percentages between 2013 and 2019
although we're meeting it as you stated it's a minor blip on the in a positive movement forward
and so I'm I'm hopeful that as you come to us in the future that we can have a discussion around
this and to the extent possible leverage the other mechanisms in the state to prioritize this
conversation such as supporting inclusive practices project and maybe even our MTSS arm to really
highlight the ideas and support the field with how do we accelerate the opportunities for students
with disabilities to be involved in the general education classroom so I'm thinking there's a
multi-agency all hands on deck approach to this indicator but again just want to thank you and
offer that as just some food for thought. Thank you. Thank you. Member Rucker. Thank you. First I
want to thank this department staff for this very detailed and very important report and Shiloh I
really do want to thank you for the explanation you gave about the work that is done on the very
technical aspects on how significant disproportionality is reported and what how the findings are developed
behind a lot of that work is also the conversation that I think is worth noting for this board there
is a work group of stakeholders from LEAs across the state concerning significant disproportionality
and I have been attending and monitoring the conversations in that work group and Shiloh
could I ask you just to talk a little bit about that particular collection of stakeholders and
the conversations they've had it's relevant to the comment we just heard from my colleague.
Absolutely so in the 2016 regulation there was a requirement that we seek input from stakeholders
on a couple of very key areas and so we pulled together a really diverse stakeholder group to
make those recommendations and they were around minimum end size and minimum cell size and what's
also known as reasonable progress and so I we have folks from LEAs we have folks from our advocacy
groups we have folks from our special education local plan areas we have teachers and parents
and so it's a pretty diverse stakeholder group and they have helped us really set I think
reasonable progress in a way that holds districts both accountable but recognizes progress when
it's being made appropriately and I think they have also had a lot of discussion about setting
targets and setting the benchmark in a way that is ensuring districts aren't sliding back
if they are making any progress. One key area that they have brought up of concern that I
think we'll continue to discuss in the department and how we'll address is the suspension expulsion.
The U.S. Department of Education did make some changes to suspension expulsion in that it
doesn't identify suspension expulsion in comparison to all students who are suspended
or expelled it identifies suspension expulsion comparing students with disabilities to all
students with disabilities and so there is a way districts you know if you identify a lot of
students with disabilities and then you suspend quite a number of them it will always trigger
the calculation. It's one of the weaknesses in the calculation so the stakeholder group
asked us to really model out what it might look like if we change either the reasonable progress
or to change the alternate risk ratio threshold and so we're looking at the department to see
sort of what the impacts that might be in the future. Those are some of the discussions we've
had it's been a really I think helpful conversation for us to have with them to ensure that we're
setting the right threshold and the right reasonable progress standards. Thank you I'm
so glad you explained that that's the reason why I asked that question and I was hoping
you would bring up the issue about the suspension and expulsion
conversation thank you very very much. Just to add one thing too as well
board member Rucker as well there there's a national conversation on the the intersection
of disability and race that largely is led by the National Center for Systemic Improvement
which is a TA center that is funded by OSEP so they are bringing thought leaders across the
country state directors, OSEP staff, LEAs and other scholars across the field to really have
a national conversation on the intersection of race and disability and really sort of digging
in in terms of how do we continue to to discuss and elevate and address some of the issues as
well so wanted to wanted to plug that in terms of just that you know we're part of a national
conversation with that as well. I appreciate knowing that I was not aware that the state had
gotten involved to that degree in that national conversation disproportionality as many of my
colleagues on the board knows this is a subject and a topic an issue that I have been monitoring
ever since I've been on the board the over representation and the over referral of African
American students of great concerns it's not enough just to lump this con this issue in this
practice into the broad category of disparity it is um what this particular report and the work
group that Shiloh described to you has done this is an example of conversations of real work
and real initiatives that have been undertaken to try to address and resolve it the participants
from the LEAs that are involved in those conversations hold themselves personally
accountable for looking for ways to improve and show gains or a correction attempts at corrections
on those issues so this is a very important conversation a very important model for ways
to address the issues of disparities that we have a broader conversation about so Heather I also want
to add my thanks and my welcome to you for coming to California I'm very excited to see your expertise
join our department and I'm very excited to see the work that you'll be able to help
help this board to lead
I don't see other hands up but I'd like to piggyback on the comments that both member
Rucker and member Navo made you know we first of all we welcome you Heather we're thrilled that
you're here and bringing together sort of the framework around what's happening in the state
there's a lot of activity in the state to invest in special education to upgrade professional
development opportunities that are beginning member Navo mentioned the initiatives around MTSS
that have also been underway it would be great if we can begin to link some of the data progress
to the actual you know activities that are underway and start to be able to track a little bit
where we are making progress and how those things may be contributing to them
Skylar I really appreciate it Shiloh I really appreciated the way that you talked about the data
and about the fact that the way the federal government asks us to report it is not always
giving us a full picture on what's going on and I would love to invite you to bring the full picture
to us along with what you have to send to the federal government on things like disproportionate
suspension and expulsion because we need to be you know similarly aware of those kinds of outcomes
as they exist in the entire population of students not just you know within
disproportionately within special education students are also disproportionately
a subject suspension and expulsion and we want again to be able to track those things in relation
to the interventions and strategies that we're putting in place to hopefully begin to see some
differences one of the points that member Navo made was that that we can use a multi-agency approach
I think that's so very important and you know much to be encouraged and one of the agencies
among many is the California teacher credentialing commission which is trying to evolve an approach
to credentialing that could support least restrictive environment placements in a much
stronger way we had a change of policy back over more than a decade ago that
changed credentialing for special education teachers for education specialists as they're
called in California such that you can become an education specialist without having been a
general education teacher first without having that core credential and then if you did come
in through that pathway you were actually not credentialed to teach regular general education
students which meant that placements it actually led to more segregation of of treatment and and
placements for special education students so we need to be moving these policies you know in sync
with each other if we're going to get to the goals that we all care about both around credentialing
room professional learning around the ways in which we structure systems and mtss so we're just
thrilled to get a window into the work that you're launching we want more we want to continue to to
learn you know what strategies are that may be working may be problematic and so we can really
contribute to the state of moving in the right direction right we want to move the needle with
you thank you both very much we can take a motion to approve the report so i will move approval of
the annual performance report prepared by the cde second second that thank you very much
and at this point we'll need to i think do is there any further discussion
we'll do a roll call vote member burr aye present darlin hamid
aye member fatah aye member glover woods yes member mcquillan yes member navo
aye member patil brownson yes member rodriguez yes member rucker yes vice president strouse
yes member son yes and thank you for this very thorough report motion carries unanimously
thank you thank you very much agenda item 17 has been withdrawn so we're going to move on
to agenda item 18 and then we'll take a break after this item item 18 is the consideration of
a retroactive request for determination of funding with reasonable basis mitigating circumstances as
required for non-classroom based charter schools and the cde recommends that the state board approve
the mitigating surface circumstances request and determination of funding requests at the percentage
for the time period as specified for the wab de bois public charter and attachment one and this
item will be presented by stephanie farland from the cde
good morning president darlin hammond and board members i am presenting the next two items along
with my colleague mckenna huey who is the manager in the charter division responsible for funding
determination reviews so we'll be going we'll both be presenting
so item 18 consists of a retroactive request for determination of funding with mitigating
circumstances for w e b de bois charter school public charter school the term retroactive is
used to refer to determination of funding requests submitted after the february 1 renewal deadline
which is prescribed by regulations because it submitted its request after the regulatory deadline
w e b de bois obtained a waiver from the state board at his july meeting thus permitting it to
submit a funding determination request to the cde it might sound familiar because this item
was previously heard at the october accs meeting and november state board meeting at
um the nove at the november meeting the state board chose not to act on this item and requested
that the cde obtain further clarification of the school's request for mitigating circumstances and
bring this item back to the state board at his january meeting after the november meeting and
at the cde's request the charter school provided additional information regarding their mitigating
circumstances request which will be discussed in further detail later in this presentation
and which the cde presented to the accs at its december meeting after considering all information
the accs moved to approve the cde's recommendation to approve the charter school's request for
mitigating circumstances and the funding determination at 100 percent for two years
to the sbe by a vote of six to one
just as a refresher background on the determination of funding process and web's request in order to
qualify for a recommendation to receive 100 funding for its non-classroom based ada a charter must
meet the following criteria spend at least 40 percent of its public revenues on instructional
certified certificated salaries and benefits spend at least 80 percent of its total revenues on
salaries and benefits spend at least 80 percent of its total revenues on instruction and instruction
related services and maintain a pupil teacher ratio that does not exceed 25 to one the cde
reviewed web's request and found that it does not meet the criteria for 100 funding as it did not
spend at least 80 percent of its total revenues on instruction and instruction related services
without the consideration of mitigating circumstances the school qualifies for a
funding determination of 85 percent however we do have this mitigating circumstance request
detailed information regarding the school's revenues and expenditures can be found in its
funding determination form which is linked in the agenda item for charter schools that do not meet
the criteria for a recommendation of 100 funding regulations permit the accs and the state board
to consider a reasonable basis or mitigating circumstances by which to make a recommendation
other than the one that results from the expenditure criteria specified mitigating
circumstances may include documented data regarding individual circumstances of the charter school
and or one-time expenses or unique or exceptional exceptional expenses without a reason of
mitigating circumstances a charter school funding rate may be reduced from 100 percent to 85 or 70
percent or may be denied at zero percent web debois submitted a request for mitigating
circumstances citing the need to expend a considerable amount of revenues on facilities
as well as a decrease in its non-classroom based ada caused by a campus closure resulting from
the anderson shasta court decision additional details regarding the request can be found in the
item all right good morning state board members um my name is mckenna hilly from the charter
schools division and i will be presenting the next couple of slides um so as stephanie has
previously mentioned at its november meeting the state board chose not to act on this item
and requested that the cde obtain clarification of the school's mitigating circumstances
specifically the state board requested clarification of the relationship between agape
schools and the ellis family partnership as well as information of the school's facility lease
agreements so cde staff did request clarifying information of the school and presented it to
the eccs at its december meeting the specific information provided by the school is detailed
in the item as well as in the eccs attachments which are also linked in the item
so regarding the relationship between agape schools and the ellis family partnership
per the information provided by wb debois agape schools entered into an operating agreement with
ellis family partnership in november 2004 for the purposes of developing a permanent charter
school facility and holding the titles of the properties that agape schools occupy
so this partnership formed agape lslc which maintains two general managers so one manager
represents agape schools and the other manager represents the ellis family partnership
neither manager is compensated nor a member of their own board and then regarding the facility
lease agreements wb debois currently leases two facilities from agape lslc one is located on p
street in fresno california and the other is located on martin luther king boulevard also in
fresno so wb debois previously served students at the p street facility which is located within
the boundaries of the fresno unified school district however it has since transitioned to
serving students entirely at the martin luther king boulevard facility and that transition
happened in the 2018-19 fiscal year so the martin luther king boulevard facility is located within
its authorizing district's boundaries and their authorizing district is washington unified school
district so although wb debois no longer serves students at the p street facility it does continue
to use that facility for central and back office services the school's use of the p street facility
has gradually decreased along with its rent obligation since it transitioned primarily
to the martin luther king boulevard facility so additional details regarding each of these
matters is available in the item and in the accs item attachments as well
so the cde has determined that the information submitted by web debois public charter school
supports its claim for mitigating circumstances and its request for 100 funding determination
therefore the cde recommends that the state board approve the school's request for mitigating
circumstances and approve its determination of funding request for 100 funding for a time period
of two years as specified in attachment one and i believe i haven't looked at all the squares but
i i believe the school is is online and available to answer questions if if needed
um yeah
okay
okay anything else that you wanted to and no i'm done with that item okay sorry sorry for the
abrupt ending okay uh so we do have the um public comment slide uh up there um and so uh we'll open
the phone line for public comment uh members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item
may do so by calling the number on this slide and entering the access code and while we're waiting
for members of the public to call in i want to first ask members burr and son if they have any
initial comments as liaisons and then i'll ask uh board members if they have any clarifications
before we turn to public comment thank you president garden hammond i'd like to make a
brief statement if that's okay um given the conversations that occurred at the acps meeting
and some that we've had at the state board i wanted to preface this next this item the next
item with a brief statement the california department of education is charged with the
following education code sections 47 612.5 and 47 634.2 and relevant sections of the california
code of regulations when reviewing funding determination requests and making recommendations
for apportionment funding for classroom-based charter schools over the past year funding
determinations have come under increased scrutiny at the accs and spe meetings with requests for
staff work investigations documentation access and funding withholding that exceed the intended
scope and purpose of the statute and regulations in some instances pending audit work and
investigation has been cited as reason to deny funding for the existing schools
as a reminder non-classroom-based charter schools may only receive apportionment funding for
classroom-based non-classroom-based instruction if a determination of funding is made by the
state board of education it's worth mentioning that these are the only type of schools in our
entire public school system that is required to go through an additional scrutiny in order to
receive funding for from the state despite the fact that a large number of these schools provide
a significant level of site-based and classroom-based instructional modes so it's important for us to
understand that these requests to deny or delay funding have considerable consequences for schools
students and teachers until such time that legislative changes are made the department
must continue to follow the process specified in law the department is granted the authority to
bring back funding determination concerns to the state board of education if new information comes
to light through audit or investigation in the case of all of the charter schools being considered
today and at prior meetings this is the appropriate course of action if concerns arise that may be
have bearing on the school's funding determination level so i really want to just commend the
department and their due diligence in securing the information that the state board members have
requested and know that the department is working appropriately within the process that they are
tasked to follow in statute having gone through this process in the past i know personally that
student staff is thorough and diligent in their work in following the current law and regulations
you'll see that in the recommendations for this item next item the funding determinations are
for a limited time so it does provide us and that they cover the current school year as well
so the limited time does give the department and the state board additional time to or
a opening to be able to review in a very short time any of the schools that are up in this item
the next item thanks thank you member Burke do you have any framing comments no i just appreciate
member Sun reminding us of what the statutory requirements are here with respect to non-classroom
based schools and also thanks Stephanie and McKenna for all of their due diligence as as Ting
mentioned i believe they went above and beyond and they really dug into this at the request of the
board from our november discussion i just would remind folks too that the accs has heard this
school now twice and both times has made a recommendation for full funding thank you
okay um i'm told that the phone bridge is experiencing some challenges so i want to
encourage uh callers to call back in if they were having any difficulty getting through
um apparently the phone bridge is being repaired so people seem to be able to get in the second
time they call so please keep trying and i think we do have some callers lined up so i'm going to
turn to the phone queue yes currently we have two people in the queue um caller this is for item
number 18 please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
my name is Lorraine Richards and i am a classroom teacher representing california teachers
association cta continues to have major concerns with the regulations that govern non-classroom
based charter funding determinations we're also extremely troubled with what appears to be a lack
of oversight from the authorizers of ncbs and the disconnect between funding determinations
and the reality of rampant issues throughout this industry there's a significant difference
there's a significant amount of co-mingling of interest and it appears that the state funds
generated by web dubois public charter are being used to benefit agape's other enterprises and agape
alice's llc with each of these entities being managed by the same person cta poses the cd's
recommendation of granting mitigating circumstances for 100 funding for two years because the reasons
they deem as mitigating circumstances were under their control due to their role as a manager of
the leap holder thank you thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record your time starts now hello it's eric premack with the charter schools development
center we're in support of and thankful for the cde and accs recommendation and for the work of
members burr and son on this and related issues the leasing arrangements here are very standard
arrangements that we see across the charter sector and many schools the school in question
here and their leader are long-standing and respected members of the charter community and
we urge your support thank you thank you there are no more callers in the queue all right
um so we'll turn to board discussion are there other board members who would like to
comment or ask a question
uh member navo yeah i appreciate very much uh stephanie your hard work and the clarity around
this i'm i agree with board member board member son and burr that there's been much effort behind
the scenes trying to rectify this but i also realize that this issue comes up has come up
several times now and the regs have been in question and is there any conversations about
how we're going to address those um did you want were you asking me member navo
you or anyone if i be able to answer that
uh i'm not aware of any yeah no we i mean we we have had conversations obviously i know
member um son has has uh requested that we gather folks and stakeholders to discuss this issue um
further and and look look at the um regulations and and possibly look at um new legislation so
those conversations is have happened and are happening um but at the moment i don't have a
sort of a timeline of of when when we'll start that work but but we certainly there's there's
a desire to do that from all sides
and i see that judy size has a comment or perhaps an answer
no pressure this is judy size i would say that um there are lots of conversations going on in the
legislature right now about this issue you may recall that as part of um ab 1505 there was a
two-year moratorium on the establishment of new non-classroom based charter schools
so we understand that there's going to be some legislation this year possibly around
non-classroom based in the funding determination process so of course any new legislation would
inform our rule making process so um we are hopeful that we'll see some legislation and
then that can lead to us reviewing the regulations but until the underlying statutory issues are
dealt with um i think we're sort of at the place that we are for now thank you member
glover woods oh let me go back um member navo did you get all of your questions answered
yes thank you okay member glover woods i just wanted to thank uh stephanie and mckenna and staff
for doing uh another look and um responding to the inquiries that were brought up at the
last board meeting thank you for doing that terrific uh seeing no more questions or comments
i want to see if we have a motion
i move to adopt the department of education recommendation on item 18 i will second thank
you tain did you say you seconded it yes great uh any further discussion all right we'll do a
roll call vote member burr aye president darling hamond aye member fatah aye member glover woods
yes member mcquillin yes member navo aye member patil brownson yes member rodriguez
yes member rocker yes vice president strous yes member son yes motion carries unanimously
thank you uh we're going to take a break until um why don't we say till 10 o'clock
we'll be generous we'll give you a 17 minute break um and then we have only one more item
after that which i'm quite confident we will finish by noon so we will see you back at 10 o'clock
back at 10 o'clock
are we back okay we're back all right terrific um brooks uh we need to reestablish a quorum so
can you uh call the roll of course member burr here president darling hamond here member fatah
here member glover woods here member mcquillin here member navo
here member patil brownson here member rodriguez here member rocker
vice president strous here member son present everyone's present quorum's established
okay so um our final item is item 19 the consideration of requests for determination
of funding as required for non-classroom based charter schools pursuant to california
education code sections 476.1.5 and 476.3.4.2 and the associated california code of regulations
title five the cde recommends that we approve the determination of funding requests at the
percentages and for the time periods as specified for the charter schools in attachment one
and the cde notes that at the december 9th 2020 accs meeting the cde had proposed a recommendation
for 85 funding for insight at san diego and insight at san joaquin based on the information
provided by both schools at that time but following the accs meeting the cde received
additional information from the schools and their auditor that addressed the outstanding
questions held by the cde as such the cde has changed this recommendation for these two schools
to 100 funding for the time periods as specified in attachment one and this item will be presented
by stephanie farland from the cde stephanie please begin thank you um so item 19 consists
regular requests for determination of funding by six renewing non-classroom based charter schools
which are listed on the slide and in the item and just for clarification
oh it actually we added that as a note so that insight schools are part of the cava organization
so just wanted to clarify that next slide as previously mentioned in order to see receive 100
funding for their non-classroom based ada charter schools must submit a request for determination
of funding to the cde and meet the following criteria spend at least 40 of its public revenues
on instructional certificated salaries and benefits and spend at least 80 of its total
revenues on instruction and instruction related services and maintain a pupil teacher ratio that
does not exceed 25 to one it is the current it is the cde's current practice upon its receipt of
complete funding determination forms to verify the information submitted on the forms with the
school's annual audits based upon its review of all information provided by the schools as part
of their funding determination request the cde determined has determined that all schools
presented in this item qualify for a 100 funding for their ncb instruction non-classroom based
instruction all schools spending percentages and pupil teacher ratio information can be found in
attachment one detailed information regarding each school's revenues and expenditures can be
found in their funding determination forms which are now provided as accs item attachments
I'm going to hand it over to McKenna for the next couple of slides
all right hello again board members so as Stephanie stated I will be
presenting on the next couple of slides this one here so the cde was previously notified of unresolved
audit findings related to kava and insights calculation of pupil teacher ratios
from the California state controller's office october 2017 audit report and because pupil
to teacher ratio information is one of the three criteria considered for a 100 determination of
funding recommendation the cde did request that additional information be submitted along with
kava and insights renewal funding determination requests specifically the cde requested that
kava and insights submit information regarding their calculation of pupil to teacher ratios
in order to ensure that these ratios were calculated and reported accurately in the
funding determination forms so the schools did provide this information to the cde and a detailed
summary of the cde's communications with these schools as well as the specific information
requested and provided are available in the item
okay and as President Darling-Hammond stated before the cde does note that at the time of the
December accs meeting the cde was proposing to recommend that the state board approve the funding
determinations for inside at san diego and inside at san joaquin which to clarify are both a part
of the kava network at 85 so when reviewing the funding determination forms for these schools
the cde found that the expenditures reported to be inconsistent with the expenditures indicated in
the school's 2018-19 annual audits so specifically it appeared that some of the school's administrative
expenses were reported as instruction and related services expenses so using the numbers provided
in both schools audits the cde found that inside at san diego and inside at san joaquin did not
meet the 80 spending threshold on instruction and instruction related services and therefore
qualified for only a recommendation of 85 funding for their non-classroom based ada
okay so the cde did request clarification from the auditor of the two inside schools
of these discrepancies found within the funding determination form and the school's audits
this clarification was provided by the auditor after the December accs meeting so the auditor
explained that some of the instruction and related services expenses were classified as
administrative support services in the audit due to differences in terminology between the
generally accepted accounting principles and the funding determination form so in the auditor's
clarification they did certify that all expenses indicated in the funding determination forms
were expensed and reported accurately and in accordance with regulations so the cde found
this explanation which was provided by the auditor to be sufficient and
has thus revised its recommendation for these schools to be 100 percent
for their non-classroom based instruction
so i'm going to hand it back over to Stephanie and Stephanie it looks like you're muted
thank you so at the accs December accs meeting the accs voted on three separate motions so they
took the one item and they divided it up into three separate motions they moved to approve the
cde's recommendation to the sb that the funding determinations for the three kava schools be
approved at 100 for two years that motion was passed on a vote of six to one so those are the
vote of six to one so those are the three that we originally recommended 100 funding they moved
the second motion was they moved to approve the cde's recommended recommendation to the sb that
the funding determinations for the two kava insight schools be approved at 85 for two years
with the caveat that should the kava insight schools provide additional information to support
a 100 recommendation the cde may change their recommendation so that both schools receive full
funding which is what we did so that was called that was the accs's recommendation on those two
schools and then they made a third motion to approve cde's recommendation to the sb
that the funding determination for caprio point academy be approved at 100 for two years however
no formal recommendation was moved to the sb on this particular school's motion because of a lack
of a quorum the motion did not pass by a vote or the the motion was made and there were four yes
votes one no vote and two abstentions and i will mention that and and i'm sure teen was on the call
at the time and she could she could member sun could certainly chime in the conversation around
cabrio point and why we had two abstentions was really around the fact that cabrio point academy
is part of a ficmat audit at the moment they are currently working with that or auditing that school
as part of the inspire audit that ficmat is conducting and i think there was some concern
we understand that there's an audit happening we do not have any reports or results i don't
believe that audit is finished yet and so i want to remind the board that if anything comes of that
audit that would impact the funding determination for this school we do have a regulatory the
regulatory ability to bring this school back and re-review their funding determination
but as there's no we have no audit exceptions now we have no reports of wrongdoing and this school
is not under revocation at their own district so we did fill based on the regulations that we need
to follow in order to approve these funding determination requests that cabrio point does
meet the requirements for 100 funding and as noted all of these schools we are renewing for two years
which gives us the ability to come back and look at them as well within two years
so we are requesting in conclusion we're we're all requesting that based on all the information
that we have gathered and reviewed the cde recommends that all schools presented in this
item be approved for 100 funding for two fiscal years okay thank you let's put up the
phone line for public comment thank you i will now open the phone line for public comment queue
members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling
the number on that slide and entering the access code while we're waiting for members
of the public to call in i want to first ask members burr and son if they have any initial
comments as our liaisons and then we'll see if we have any other clarifying questions before we
turn to public comment
member sun member burr i made my comment in the last item
so it still holds member burr do you want to add anything now just again my deep appreciation to
stephanie and mckenna for being so diligent and following through on questions that are raised
about these schools and to reinforce what member sun said they are following the law terrific thank
you so are there any clarifying questions before we turn to public comment seeing none we will see
if there's anyone in the public comment queue yes we we do have two callers remember this is for
item 19 caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
eric premack with the charter school center again and same comment as with the prior item
thank you caller
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello my name is lorraine richards and i am a classroom teacher representing the california
teachers association cta believes that it is it is inappropriate for the state board to approve
100 funding determination of even two years when there is such a significant amount of alleged
fraud and improprietary surrounding cabrio point academy and the inspire schools cabrio point is
set to receive 42 million per year as highlighted in the letter from california virtual educators
in the letter from california virtual educators united kava and insight schools have a history
of prior prioritizing the revenue generated for k-12 inc over the needs of their educators
and students cta believes that there must be more oversight and transparency with these ncbs
and to remind everyone that the a3 administrators had very similar business practices signed the
same forms and made the same affirmations as these ncbs on their way to scandal thank you
thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts
now my name is erica van der speck and i'm with cabrio point academy we serve 4,500 students many
of whom need individualized learning plans and flexible schedules because they are at promise
medically fragile facing mental health challenges transitioning genders and students pursuing
employment or special interests what you've heard from cta is not correct or has been resolved
we've distanced ourselves from inspire to fully operate the school independently
we're cooperating with all audits and there have been no findings our funding determination
application meets all expenditure tests so we respectfully urge the state board to follow cde's
recommendation to approve cabrio points funding determination to allow us to continue serving
the students who depend on us thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record your time starts now good morning board members my name is jenna lorge senior
director of cabrio point academy we are urging the state board to follow cde staff recommendation
to approve cabrio point academy's funding determination request at 100 percent throughout
this process we have promptly responded to and addressed all of cde staff's request and we will
continue to be cooperative in cde's recommendation they note cabrio must receive the state board's
approval in order to continue to receive funding for this school year we are in the middle of the
school year in the middle of the pandemic and we need your approval to continue operating our school
and to prevent significant harm to our staff our community and our thousands of students that are
working so hard thank you thank you caller this concludes public comment okay we'll open up for
board discussion are there any comments or questions for members of the board
i am oh member rucker thank you i just wanted to be get a clarification from stephanie i want to
make sure i heard this correctly because of the ongoing audit activities i want to make sure i
understood you to say that if there are findings that have an impact on the decision the board
would make today that there are regulatory remedies available to the department and the
board to make corrections on the funding determination is that correct yes member
rucker that is correct we do have and the board has regulatory
allowances to bring back any non any charter school the non-funding determination
to re-review their funding determination and make any corrections
okay and i understand that there's a there are timeline issues involved with the funding
determination process and this the this particular charter is on the agenda today because um they've
asked you they followed the due diligence and responded to the staff as you were preparing
decided but is there a reason why the board cannot wait to make this uh
funding determined nation decision until after the audit work is completed
there there are funding determinations and and the board and and mckenna please jump in if if i'm
not uh saying this correctly um but there are funding uh there are deadlines and the deadlines
do impact funding depending on when these happen versus uh the the board's approval before p1 and
p2 and i do believe that uh we do need to make these decisions um this month for these schools
to not impact their funding um and i'm not sure when figmat will be finished with their audit
um i know this is not the only school that is part of the uh complete audit i know there are
several schools and so i don't have a timeline for when that audit might be finished okay so you're
so part of this is we have these deadlines because the p1 and p2 and to make sure that
there's a continuing revenue stream but also it's not really clear when thick map would actually
complete their process for for this to come back um in a timely way right and and you know this is
this is uh this particular item that we're approving them for two years i would think
that the audit would be finished within um that time um so we we certainly i i firmly believe we
will have time to bring this school back if anything comes up in the audit that would impact
what our decision is here today and you read my mind i was going to ask you do you believe
the audit would be completed within the period of time that you're recommending since the two
years is less is is a shorter time frame than these would normally be approved for you do believe
figmat should complete the audit within the two years i mean i can't predict for sure because i
don't work for figmat but the audit has been going on for a little bit of time so certainly
it will um and and just to remind the board and and i didn't mention this in the in the presentation
but normally these uh renewal items we normally approve them for three to four years and because
we know there are so many concerns um we did limit this particular school to a two-year renewal so
even if um the audit isn't finished we're bringing this school back
much sooner than we do other renewals i see that you besides is waiting to make a comment so let
me turn to judy real quick um yes i just i just want to add that i think maybe stephanie mentioned
it two years is the minimum amount of time that we can give a renewals a renewing school so we
are giving them the minimum amount of time and as stephanie has already stated they will have to
come back much sooner than other renewing schools would given that there is the figmat audit going
on yeah we've been talking with mike fine and it's just not completed yet so there are just
no conclusions we can draw at this time i understand it i thank you very much for giving
it for adding that information judy my concern is i have major concerns about this particular
lea and with the motion as it's proposed all of these would be lumped into one motion i
um and i would vote no just because i have this concern about this one lea is it possible
to divide the motion so that the board can consider these recommendations separately
that's what i'm asking um as a process question judy um yes we can are you thinking member record
that we would do the insight schools as one motion and then cabrio point i mean kava schools all the
kava schools which are kava in insight and as one and then the cabrio point inspire one is
the separate is that what you were thinking it would make it easier for me not to vote no on
all of them yes that's what the accs did um i think stephanie mckenna can you go back to the
one slide that lists all of the schools and um there you go so we could do um california
virtual academy at king's inside at san diego inside at san joaquin california virtual academy
sonoma and california virtual academy sutter is one motion and then we could do caprio point
as a second motion is that right member record okay yes yes that's what that's my request
and i think that uh you are the there are no further hands raised for comment at this time
i can so seeing none you could oh member son yeah i was going to say that i
would be happy to make um two separate motions i will say that i not change the recommendation
or my my support of the city recommendation for point uh because it is one of the two years
is this year in which they are operating in service students and we know that the end of
the year will come just like that and then um and they would have had to reapply again in
february for the next year if you um so i don't know i just thought it would be um
difficult for us uh for to make any additional changes to us given that they have already the
minimum recommendation so uh i understand if you don't feel that as i said they um i understand
if you don't feel that dividing the motion uh simply so that i could vote no against caprio
point which would matter that much you don't have to divide the motion and i'll just vote no
i'm just asking if that's possible if you don't want to divide the motion
for the reasons that you just stated i perfectly understand that
well i was going to call for a motion so um and i think judy wants to make another
comment before we do that yeah i just remember rucker i you weren't recommending any changes
to the percentages or the years is that correct just to make sure i understand
you just wanted to have two separate votes correct okay so either of you could make a motion and it
could be one motion or two judy do you want to raise your hand again no yes all right so
what i will do is i will go ahead and make the motion that we approve cde's recommendation
for the california virtual academy uh schools and the insight schools
all right there's a motion on the table do i have a second for that motion i second the motion
all right uh any further discussion of that motion all in favor oh we need to do a roll call vote
brooks may can you do that member burr aye president darling hammond aye member fatah
aye member glover woods yes member mcquillin yes member navo
oh he had to step away for a minute member patil brownson yes member rodriguez
yes member rucker yes vice president strouse yes member son yes the motion carries
thank you uh and now i think we need another motion do i have a an additional motion
regarding cabrillo point
i will make the motion to approve cd's recommendation for cabrillo point and i
wanted to also point out that we are still operate in the premise in this democracy that
we are innocent until proven guilty so while there may be speculation that we do not have
the results yet and i do not get comfortable making a determination of this particular
um determination of this after the audit is completed so you've made the motion do i have
a second for that motion i'd like to second the motion and also say that we've just experienced
in our country what happens when allegations are made that are unproven and so i hope that we will
abide by the principle of making sure that allegations are actually proven before we
punish the school so we have a motion we have a second is there any further discussion of the
motion so i just want to say that um this has nothing to do with the allegations but with our
process and the timeline and my concerns about what it is that's being done uh in the process
of this audit so while i'm sure that neither one of my colleagues want to impugn my reputation
or my intent by raising the objections to this particular hundred percent funding determination
i would have otherwise supported the funding determination if it had remained somewhere south
of 100 percent until the audit was completed so i won't be i won't raise ire or concern
at the suggestion that i have nefarious intent with on not supporting this motion we can talk
about that later in a non-public forum if you want to all right any other further discussion of the
motion all right uh brooks can you call the roll number burr aye president darlin hammond
aye member fatah aye member glover woods yes member mcquillan yes uh member navo
i believe he's still up member patil brownson yes member rodriguez yes member rucker no vice
president strouse yes member son yes motion carries all right and i want to congratulate
all the members of the board for having accomplished this very robust agenda
in record time i am now prepared to adjourn the january 2021 state board of education meeting
at 10 29 a.m thank you and i look forward to seeing you all in our march 2021 meeting
take care